sprechen wir über die derzeitige lage
mit 300 deko für langjähriger co
vorsitzender von bündnis 90 die grünen
in den jahren 2002 bis 2008 und seit
2009 im europäischen parlament habe
bütikofer
die koffer wenn sie jetzt noch mal grün
vorsitzender wären in der jetzigen
situation worum ging es ihnen dann in
den kommenden gesprächen
ich glaube die fiktion braucht man nicht
um klar zu sehen dass es eine ganz
schwierige situation ist vor der wir
stehen
eine solche gab es noch nicht in der
deutschen politischen landschaft denn
der stärkste partner einer möglichen
koalition hätte egal wer es
weniger als 26 prozent und wenn es schon
eine ampel kommen sollte würde das
bedeuten dass fdp und grünen also die
junior partner zusammen mehr sie zu
haben als die spd der cdu gegenüber
sowieso dann zeigt sich denke ich in den
letzten tagen sehr deutlich dass die
union eigentlich
noch nicht mal
gesprächsfähig ist die
zersetzt sich ja auf offener bühne
zerlegt sich
von daher scheint mir
ich glaube dass jetzt keine besonders
exotische prognose dass die größte
wahrscheinlichkeit für eine ampel
koalition spricht aber um die zustande
zu bringen muss man nicht nur über
verschiedene farben spekulieren und in
welcher reihenfolge da die verschiedenen
farben angeordnet werden so man muss
über die schutz tanz reden und da gibt
erhebliche unterschiede die bewältigt
werden muss dann versuche es mal anders
herr bütikofer was erwarten sie jetzt
von der jetzigen grünen-spitze gerade
wenn sie sagen es gibt erhebliche
unterschiede mit fdp und vielleicht auch
spd
ich erwarte dass sie den kurs weiter
führen den sie jetzt eingeschlagen haben
ich halte das für außerordentlich klug
zunächst mal mit der fdp zu reden denn
da sind die gegensätze am eklatantesten
und ich finde aber auch klug sich darauf
einzustellen und das spricht ja aus den
worten von annalena baerbock dass es mit
einer ziemlichen wahrscheinlichkeit am
schluss auf einer von olaf scholz
geführte regierung hinauslaufen wird sie
haben am sonntag nach der wahl in der
columbiahalle gesagt jetzt gehe es darum
das eisen zu schmieden mit sicht auf die
grünen sollen jetzt mal teilen der
regierung werden und dann eben auch in
die regierung gehen um welchen preis
soll dieses eisen geschmiedet werden
noch mal wenn sie sagen es gibt
erhebliche unterschiede
na ja aber das ist doch für sie als
erfahrenen journalisten klar dass wir
sondierungsgespräche und auch
koalitionsgespräche nicht auf offener
bühne führen und schon gar nicht wenn
ich das tun der ich damit gar nicht
beauftragt den herrn was wir in einer
neuen regierung erreichen wollen ist
doch klar
darum ging der ganze wahlkampf ganz
was wir in einer solchen regierung
erreichen wollen ist meines erachtens
sehr deutlich geworden in dem ganzen
wahlkampf in
zentraler weise geht es darum dass die
nächste regierung eine klima regierung
sein wird was heißt das klima regierung
helmut hofer also was musste aus ihrer
sicht drin stehen ohne dass sie jetzt
ihr wahlkampf machen oder die gespräche
schon selbst führen über uns hier bei
phoenix werden wir interessant aber klar
wir müssen sie nicht aber was muss aus
ihrer sicht da wirklich eben drinnen
stehen was muss am ende eben gerade aus
ihrer aus klima perspektive
gewährleistet sein um am ende sagen zu
können diese regierung lohnt sich für
sie
über die instrumente die man auswählen
wird wird sicher hart gerungen werden
und dann wird man schwierige
entscheidungen zu treffen haben aber
klar muss sein dass man sich um diese
fragen nicht drückt das man nicht nur
überschriften produziert die dann in der
luft hängen weil nicht klar ist wie man
dahin kommen will wo man ziele in den
raum stellt und zum zweiten muss auch
das ziel
ambitioniert sein und wir haben das im
wahlkampf immer wieder gesagt und das
gilt danach wieder vor
deutschland muss auf einen 105 grad
fahrt kommen das heißt wir müssen auf
einen pfad kommen mit welchen maßnahmen
auch immer der es erlaubt den
klimawandel der ja schon stattfindet er
ja keine zukunfts drohung mehr ist so
einzuhegen dass das dass die erwärmung
möglichst noch auf maximal 15 grad
begrenzt wird jetzt würden
wahrscheinlich die fdp mit gehen bei dem
1,5 grad ziel aber vielleicht wird's
schon da schwierig aber bei denen genau
wie sie es gesagt haben mitteln gibt es
doch enorme unterschiede also wenn sie
dann sagen da müssen wir einfach auch
viel mehr von unternehmen fest verlangen
über im zweifel klare auch rechtliche
vorgaben wird die fdp ihr sicherlich
sagen sind wir nicht dabei
naja moment mal unsere politik kann man
glaube ich nicht so zusammenfassen dass
wir sagen würden wir verlangen einfach
von den unternehmen und kümmern uns dann
nicht darum ob da eben realismus
dahinter steckt sondern wir haben das
hat annalena baerbock persönlich im
wahlkampf nach vorne geschoben wir haben
angebote formuliert die wirtschaft wo
wir konkrete wege aufzeigen wie man die
erforderliche innovation mit staatlicher
unterstützung jetzt schnell angehen kann
so dass auf der einen seite die
klimapolitik davon profitiert auf der
anderen seite aber auch die mittel und
langfristige wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unserer unternehmen gestärkt wird ich
glaube eine fdp die ihre eigene
marktwirtschaftliche orientierung ernst
nimmt müsste das eigentlich interessant
finden und die spd auf wir sind gespannt
rainer tico für europa parlamentarier
der grünen und langjähriger coo
vorsitzender auch von den vielen dank
ihnen herr bütikofer
ich grüße sie aus brüssel